bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous
donald trump qui menace donc de
suspendre le congrès il peut le faire il
a une peau utilisé un pouvoir
constitutionnel ce serait une première
non non il peut pas le faire en réalité
il faudrait que les deux champs soient
d'accord pour qu'il le fasse au plus tôt
il faudrait que les deux chambres ne
soit pas d'accord au d'ajournement pour
que lui interviennent c'est l'article 2
section 3 de la constitution qui n'est
d'ailleurs pas nous mais dans les
journaux et qui est très clair à ce
sujet là le président peut convoquer une
session il ne peut pas la journée c'est
d'ailleurs il ya aucune raison de le
faire puisque le congrès est en session
actuellement et il est simplement en pro
forma c'est à dire que ce qui se passe
en ce moment au concret c'est qu' il n'y
a que quelques représentants pour des
raisons sanitaires tout le monde le
comprend et que comme il n'y a que
quelques parlementaires qui représentent
tous les autres il ya une quasi
unanimité dont il n'y a que les dossiers
de vraiment quasi unanimité qui passe et
c'est bien ce qui embête donald trump
qui aimerait bien que les choses bouger
un petit peu plus et pas simplement en
bi partisan mais il nous a fait des
annonces ces derniers jours qu'ils sont
un petit peu étrange dans lequel ils
essaient de montrer qu'il a une autorité
sur la crise en cours c'est ça le
véritablement qui est en jeu ici parce
que il est contesté sur sa gestion tout
simplement parce qu'au départ de la
crise il ne l'a pas pris suffisamment
sérieusement et aujourd'hui il est
rattrapé par ce déni qui a été le sien
jusqu'au 11 mars
même si après s'est bien comportée
puisqu'il ya eu un état d'urgence
fermeture des frontières et une prise en
compte
très sérieuse de cette crise et même une
bonne collaboration avec les gouverneurs
il faut le dire maintenant qu on se
dirige vers la sortie
c'est vrai que la politique reprend ses
droits et donald trump se trouve bien
embêté avec cet héritage qu'il va devoir
défendre donc il essaie d'allumer un
contre-feu est de montrer que ça peut se
passer ailleurs
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'ils menacent le
congrès alors ça c'est une grande
question et c'est d'autant plus étrange
que il a tellement besoin des congrès
aujourd'hui
sans le congrès menace également les
républicains or les républicains et en
avoir non seulement besoin pour faire
face à la crise dans l'immédiat mais
ensuite pour être réélu et ça ça arrive
très vite un sel 3 novembre quand même
donc non non c'est on va dire union qui
a fourché tout comme quand il disait
qu'il avait l'autorité pour couvrir le
pays c'est un ranger dans la même boîte
alors sur la gestion de la crise c'est
le point faible en ce moment pour donald
trump
il affirme qu'il souhaite aujourd'hui
relancer l'économie peut-être avant le
1er mai que faut-il en penser
bien entendu qui veut relancer
l'économie il a raison d'ailleurs devoir
relancer l'économie c'est un drame
affreux qui est en train de tomber sur
les états unis au rendez vous compte
c'était et il nous le disait à davos
c'était fin janvier il disait l'économie
américaine est la meilleure économie du
monde celle qui marche le mieux et c'est
vrai que les chiffres lui donner raison
on disait d'ailleurs qu'il allait être
réélu très facilement en tout cas la
plupart des commentateurs des et cela
mais cette crise qui lui tombe dessus
renverse tous ses plans en verse tous
les plans de l'amérique et surtout avec
beaucoup de malheurs et une crise
sociale et économique qui s'annonce sur
les états unis et qui est sans précédent
en long on a les chiffres du chômage qui
sont tombés aujourd'hui en tout cas les
ceux qui se sont inscrits comme
demandeurs d'emploi
les chiffres du chômage qui tomberont
dans quelques jours vont être affreux
puisque ils vont dépasser à nouveau 10 %
alors qu'on était tombé à 3,5
bien entendu d'être voudrait rouvray
l'économie encore une fois il n'en a pas
le pouvoir c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre tout président des états unis
qu'il est aujourd'hui c'est ceux qui ont
confiné qui peuvent dés confiné ce sont
donc les gouverneurs qui ont la main et
donald train va s'en tenir à des
conseils à des indications à ce sera
même pas des injonctions puisque des
injonctions vous serez suivi d'effet il
va espérer tout le monde suive et il va
être suivie dans certains états du
centre des états unis très ruraux qui
sont républicains et qui vont le suivre
rapidement
mais ça va vraiment être très limité et
juste 7
dernière question sur le plan
strictement sanitaire puisque les états
unis sont devenus le foyer de la
pandémie
là encore son action à son action elle
est comme celle de la plupart des chefs
d'états dans le monde dont elle est de
courir après après ce qu'il peut courir
essayer de rattraper malheureusement les
chiffres ils sont ils sont horribles
aujourd'hui elle en a passé la barre des
trente mille morts six cent cinquante
mille cas enfin c'est juste gigantesque
c'est pas un rapport par rapport à la
population tout ça n'a pas de sens c'est
juste une chiffre lui-même fait horreur
parce que ce sont vraiment des morands
trop et que les américains ont peur donc
sa gestion crise qui a été très
compliqué au début puisque il expliqué à
ses supporters notamment à ce meeting en
caroline du sud dans laquelle il disait
à ses supporters que c'était une intox
inventé par les démocrates il y les
inciter tel quel à ne pas respecter la
distanciation sociale les gestes
barrières et tout ça a laissé des traces
puisque ça a donné du retard mais
aujourd'hui l'opinion se retourne peu
contre lui un sondage paru hier expliqué
que même les républicains pensent à 31%
qu'il faut ouvrir le pays ce qui veut
dire qu ils sont 70% à être plus que
sceptique et qui pense surtout à leur
préservation
et là dessus donald trump a tort de
vouloir aller trop vite
merci beaucoup jean eric branaa je
rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste des
états unis est maître de conférences à
l'université à ça ça parait de remercier
à vous